[Music]
here's a new segment called delony was
wrong
i just made that segment up
kelly's like ooh
i like this segment i'm in for this yes
um so
i i'm always giving advice and running
my mouth and blah blah blah on the show
i don't think i'm yeah i guess i do give
advice or i give my opinion on things or
what i would do in my situation
um
but sometimes i'm wrong and i think it's
important as
scientists i think it's important as
people who are um
espousing their views on things to say
yeah i missed this one and here's one
where i missed it
and i brought some friends in to help
so i have for years talked about the
importance of loneliness and the i mean
the import not the importance of
loneliness the importance of having
friends having community and how awful
loneliness is and how it kills us both
physiologically and emotionally
psychologically spiritually we just die
younger right we're not designed to live
alone
and
i also think it's i thought it's really
not a good idea to become best buddies
to have your intimate go-to folks be
people that you work with
because there comes a moment when i may
have to fire you
or i may have to tell you that i blew
something up in my marriage or that i
took money that wasn't mine i did
something that's gonna force you to
think of the business
that we both share
or the workplace that we both share and
you're gonna have to consider my actions
there too
which is gonna make me be less
open
less vulnerable less honest and that's
not friendship then we have secrets we
have things that i don't tell here and i
don't tell there so i've always been a
big fan of gotta have good working
relationships no question about it you
got people that you trust no question
about it
but your 2 am friends don't need to be
at work with you they need to be out
elsewhere
you don't need to be sitting around
talking about work all day long all that
stuff
and then my buddies ryan and josh of the
minimalist
swung swing by and part of our
conversation when they're here i asked
him hey
y'all are best of best friends
and y'all run this company together
the minimalist
and in this company you are always
giving each other opinions and advice
and you all differ on a lot of stuff
how do y'all remain friends and run this
business
and
we talked about loneliness talking about
friendship
but i gotta say i was wrong
and i've they this conversation actually
changed my opinion
on
forced me to rethink this idea of
um
not being friends close friends of
people you work with so
check out this conversation i have with
my good friends josh and ryan of the
minimalist on loneliness friendship and
working with friends right here
i want to talk about um loneliness and
friendship um okay um so here's the
here's the
the some of this is spurred on by your
book love people use things because the
opposite never works which i think is
the greatest title in the last three or
four years of a book i love thanks thank
you so um we did a survey here a
national survey this is a research uh
back survey here's some of the data
points we came out came back with 82
percent of people say they're friends
and people they spend most of the time
they're most of their time with don't
know them deeply
so eight out of ten okay
um believe that folks don't know they're
struggling with their weight or their
faith or they're not attracted to their
spouse anymore that they like bieber's
music like they really like it but their
friends don't know that who doesn't
exactly
68
say they have three or fewer close
friends right so 7 out of
more than half do not have a
friend they feel comfortable calling in
the middle of the night
and half about 50 of married couples
admit to struggling with sexual intimacy
um and emotional intimacy they can't
tell the one person that they committed
like you're my ride or die i can't tell
even that person
so going back to the title of your most
recent book is love people use things
because option never works i've been
speaking about loneliness for years but
after spending time with you guys i've
got a new perspective and it's this i i
wonder if it's rooted in a consumer
culture
it tells us i can get all the stuff that
i need so that i can be okay and i can
do life by myself so here's my broad
questions and we can run with this where
we want to
what's your thoughts on a life will
lived because that to me is the end and
if we reverse engineer that to what does
it look like in the in the hour by hour
and minute by minute we can get to some
of these answers um and what's the
importance of community and friends um
let's start by talking about the
commodification of love okay because
that's really what we've done you sort
of alluded to it there we we treat
relationships transactionally so the
title of the book was love people use
things because the opposite never works
ryan and i tried the opposite for a very
long time loving things oh and we hear
it all the time i love my truck i love
my house yeah and but i also love my
wife right same word yes we don't have
different words to describe what we're
really trying to say here is i enjoy
this truck right
but also what we're saying is this truck
says something about me this couch says
something about me nothing wrong with
owning a truck i own one nothing wrong
with owning a couch i own one right but
as soon as it becomes part of my
identity a lot of people are struggling
with identity right now and the way that
we think we have a shortcut to identity
is what by heaping
new masses of things the average
american household has 300 000 items in
it and that'd be great if it was
bringing us more joy more connection
more community however i will say this i
want to be careful not to prescribe
something because having more friends
isn't better that's relationship
consumerism it's it's and it's been
amplified with social media right i've
got 3 000 friends on the internet i just
got nobody to come help me fix my air
conditioner right right i've got all
this but i have nothing i have friends
in quotes but i don't have the people
who i have that intimate relationship
with i will say this i have two really
deep friendships in my life one is ryan
one is my wife it doesn't mean that i
don't have other friends i can turn to
and i'm grateful for those friends but
the relationships that i that i have
i've cultivated in a way where i don't
need a thousand relationships
because with same thing with material
possessions i own some things and i get
immense value from those things but
relationships are different it's not
just about getting value from the people
in my life that's a parasitic
relationship yeah it's also about
contributing to the people around me
yeah in the book we wrote about the
three different types of relationships
sort of the primary relationships in our
life usually you can count those on one
hand if you're mormon or catholic it's
two hands
so your closest friends your family your
kids maybe your parents to a certain age
but beyond that you have the sort of
secondary relationships those are the
people who are the other cast members in
your film so to speak the people that
you love that you care for that you
appreciate
and
those people
we often spend
a decent amount of time but we
unfortunately forsake the people closest
to us spend time with those people or
the third layer of people the sort of
tertiary relationships the people on the
periphery we spend a lot of time with
people who are co-workers and networking
buddies and acquaintances nothing wrong
with those people but if i'm spending 95
of my time
away from the people that i love that i
care about
i'm not making time for them but i'm
also not making time for my most
important relationship was my my
relationship with me yeah
yeah
yeah i think like there's this um
incompleteness that maybe everyone kind
of feels a little bit and we're always
finding trying to find a way to be
completed and the things is a shortcut
to that and we get told by 5000
advertisements a day that here's what's
going to complete you
and i would even posit that it's not
that people complete us either um i
think
we can have meaningful relationships
once we kind of realize that we are
complete by ourselves
and uh
yeah i mean you know josh and i luckily
we knew each other in grade school so by
proximity we became friends but often
like people are stuck with proximity
with friends and they kind of you know
start to friend people who um they see
every single day and these relationships
aren't always the best relationships
right right yeah they're convenient
right yeah right so i um and we've
talked about this in other places but
that when our brain recognizes that
we're alone
it can be proximal or it can be
emotional right and we've all probably
had experiences when i'm surrounded by
people that quote unquote love me and
that i love but i feel totally alone
right yeah and vice versa you can be
with that one i was with two
knuckleheaded dudes this weekend in
texas that i've known for
and i was completely
and i think it's i love that other
people don't complete you
for me or i think for our neurologically
other people allow our brains to go
and then we can i can look in the mirror
and see the truth right then i'm not
trying to fight and look for the right
label that completes me i love that yeah
so uh what's you mentioned you got two
really important ride or dies in your
life what about you man yeah uh you know
i'm a pretty big extrovert okay so i
make friends really really easy and i
live in los angeles which
has some amazing people like there's so
many i can't even um hang out with them
all it's like i find myself like you
know struggling to hang out with this
person do i hang out with that person
but i mean as far as like close
tight-knit relationships my wife josh
um and then there's a couple other uh
they're probably more secondary okay um
but yeah i i do
enjoy hanging out with people and i you
know i think a lot of people would
probably call me their friend
um and vice versa
uh but yeah man as an extrovert i yeah i
try to seek out as many people as
possible i love it you know you brought
up um a life well lived yeah and it's
interesting because um
if we're not clear on what we want out
of life
uh we can find ourselves
you know forging these bonds that really
aren't that strong of bonds so how do
you figure out what you want well uh
josh and i mean we talk a lot about how
it starts with your values like you got
to get clear on what it is you value
and you can go to the minimalists.com
forward slash v as in values and there's
actually a worksheet there
that um help you unpack the different
things that that you uh that you want to
get out of life and that's really the
meaningful life it's our short terms our
short-term actions aligning with these
long-term values yeah and sometimes we
choose friends and we don't really line
those two up right and uh you want to
unpack the like i want i want to be
successful
and i surround myself every day with
folks who just want to get high right
yeah exactly so i'm trying i've tethered
myself here and i'm running yeah yeah
yeah um do you want to unpack the
different layers of values yeah sure i
mean our values aren't what we yeah
quite often not what this we say they
are i can say my health is a value my
relationships are a value of mine but if
all i'm doing is out you know getting
drunk and and uh you know whatever it is
like it
though however you spend your time those
are your actual values yeah so what we
talk about with that worksheet um
you have four different types of values
and so you sort of have it's like
building a house every house has a
foundation every foundation is pretty
much the same
well hey what do you want your
foundation to look like john no one asks
you that because a foundation dirty yeah
right and so everyone has similar
foundational values relationships health
contribution creativity passion etc
there are these different foundational
values fairly similar beyond that though
what makes your house look different
makes you different individual are the
structural values the structure of your
house can be a little bit different your
walls are going to be in different
places some people want a giant open
floor plan other people want six
bedrooms and
nothing is right or wrong there it's
what's appropriate for you right yeah
beyond that you have surface values
that's what makes your house look
interesting or beautiful right so like
what what are you going to paint the
house what kind of facade are you going
to have right now we misprioritize these
things we were talking to dave ramsey
yesterday i was at the airport um a
couple weeks ago
and there was this terrible shooting
that happened
and they it was on the news at the
airport and they broke in breaking news
verdict on the johnny depp amber heard
tribe
and that's what we're doing with our
personal lives right now is is we're
breaking news with banalities and sort
of
the vapid you know cultural references
that make us feel some sort of dopamine
hit in the moment
but it doesn't complete us right now i
will say a thing about the complete
thing quite often that we experience a
void and emptiness right
and we try to fill that void with stuff
with relationships with chemicals with
substances whatever it is as opposed to
realizing like hey i'm already complete
and the void isn't a bad thing
necessarily emptiness isn't a bad thing
yeah we lived in montana for five years
no one goes to
the mountains they're like that is so
freaking empty here
where are they gonna fill this this guy
is too empty right in montana yes you
know we need consumer purchases that
would be great put some bounce houses
out here on the field
right yeah and so i think also
recognizing that empty feeling that we
experience as that pascal quote about
all of humanity's problems stem from
man's inability to sit alone in a room
quietly yeah and that is that's us yeah
we
we can't sit here
and be comfortable with the emptiness so
we try to fill it not recognizing we're
not filling it we're just cluttering the
space
so i
i have struggled with this personally in
my professional career
and
any tips you all have
we you mentioned earlier we spend so
much time with the people that we work
with
and early on in my career
i was working with some of my best
friends in the world yeah and we
ended up in the same
worship places we ended up in the same
grocery stores and the same movie
theaters and the same we watch the
fights together whatever
and then it comes the day when one
person screws up or there's a there's a
moral violation or character violation
or they lose their job and
and suddenly you can't go to the grocery
store you can't go to the movie theater
because your circle's untethered and so
i wrongly hit the pendulum too far and
said
all of my close relationships are going
to be the people that i don't do work
with every day and i've come to believe
that i screwed that up i hit i went too
far
um
with without like i this can get kind of
irony kind of fast um so we don't have
to do that but
how have you two managed to stay close
friends and also do business together
because there's an inherent tension
there you know yeah no that's a great
question you know i think
josh and i well first off i see him as a
mentor and i think he probably looks at
me as a little bit of a mentor so we
have this like very
uh
very symbiotic relationship that um we
both hold very dear yeah and i think
with a business partnership a friendship
a romantic partnership
i mean the whole goal we have a romantic
partner no i'm talking about
[Laughter]
regardless of the kind of relationships
that we have in our life what do we want
out of those relationships regardless of
whether it's romantic or not we want to
be understood we want to be respected we
want to be seen
and and that is really what i go out of
my way to do with all of my
relationships i go out of my way to um
you know not just do that but also add
value to that relationship there's like
a
um
an us box right like how how much are
you how much am i giving to this us box
is something i will ask of myself a lot
and if i'm not giving anything to it and
the relationship is tumultuous then i've
got to look in the mirror and be like
okay what have i not done that i really
should probably do to get this
relationship back on track and i think
you know the the thing that really kind
of screws up relationships a lot are
expectations
you know we've got all these expected
especially the ones where you know uh
you you expect uh you know someone to do
something and they don't they don't do
it and then you get mad yeah because
they didn't do it but they didn't even
know about that particular expectation
exactly right so i mean i think that's
another piece of it too is like i don't
expect anything of josh i don't expect
anything of my wife um i uh the only
thing i expect is for myself to hold a
high level of standards and i think
that's um what really helps me
do great with relationships low
expectations high standards
yeah
john i got to tell you that that one of
the biggest things that has helped
ryan's in my relationship is a lack of
self-righteousness
because he and i have different
political beliefs yep we voted for two
different people in the last election
can you believe it oh my god um and you
know we have different religious beliefs
spiritual beliefs and we have different
personalities as well
and
it'd be easy for me to to stand on a
pedestal and say well you know i'm right
i'm going to drag ryan up to this
pedestal with me and until he gets up
here i'm going to look down on him and
it'd be easy for him to do the same
thing to me i'm going to look down at
you because you're not on my level we
have different opinions about something
right but our opinions often block
our ability to love other people to love
someone is to see them for who they are
without trying to change them you may
hope for the best for them but good luck
dragging them kicking and screaming to
your world view that's right a man
convinced against his wills of the same
opinion still right yes
and so
it's not i never want to convince him
coerce him persuade him even if anything
i want to understand where he's coming
from yeah and that's what it comes down
to like really trying to understand and
you know
when you have an understanding you can
have brutally honest truth with one
another
because you know josh could you know say
to me um hey man i noticed whatever you
know and insert criticism there
and i understand that he's trying to
help me he's not trying to put me down
he's not trying to feel better than me
yes and uh instead of me getting
offended
um i will look at it and like and try to
understand like okay where is he coming
from
the problem is there's a lot of
friendships where people
they they do just want to put the other
person down and that's we really we've
got to watch out for that for sure i
i think that's super important um
it comes back to that word that nobody
likes um that vulnerability like i've
got to put myself in a position where
you could hurt me if you wanted to yeah
yeah and i am going to trust that you
won't and
um i'm gonna be like you mentioned i'm
gonna be open about what i need i'm
gonna be clear about that
and
i'm going to
take a knee here and if you do the same
thing then we can do anything right if
that's the way we approach one another
we can do anything right i would i would
you know posit that no one can really
um like make you angry or hurt you so to
say yeah if you if you do open yourself
up and allow them to have that space in
your heart then
that is a decision that you make so i
allow four or five people in yeah and i
actually called them and told them
yeah like hey i've given you permission
so if you speak into i had one buddy the
story the he's a 50 he's the ceo of a
lawn care company right uh but he's an
old buddy that i trust and he's about 10
years older than me and
somebody posted something about how what
a loser i was and i screenshot it and
responded back and i'm not gonna lie my
response was hilarious it was pretty
funny i thought it was great
and he calls me laughing he's like dude
i just saw that hilarious and i was like
yeah that was great he goes take it down
and i said no man that's super funny
because it's super funny and he goes
that's not who you want to be take him
down yeah and i got pissed then i got
indignant and i took it down yeah and
cause i know that he didn't call me
because i had a funnier joke than he did
that day right he was just some random
guy driving his mower in texas and
realized this guy thought that was funny
but it put him in this right he had my
best interest at heart 100 percent vice
versa right if i ever recall so um it's
been able to hear that man yeah you got
to be you got to be careful with who you
open that up to oh yeah josh has
definitely talked me out of responding
to some trolls here and there for sure
because i used to respond and be funny
and witty and make light of it um but
yeah uh he's definitely talking about
that before too the problem is it's
always escalating in any loving
relationship we want to de-escalate yeah
because what he was talking about
earlier like i don't have the power to
upset you john you have the power to
upset you
and that's one of the most difficult
things to realize because my daughter
can upset me from she's nine and she can
upset me but actually she can't
she only can if i give her that power
it's within me to determine whether or
not i react in a particular way and the
same thing is true with a online troll
as well and we have
we could talk about that forever we have
a culture that
man we have just given the keys to the
kids and
they've found themselves responsible for
the emotional reactivity of the adults
in their lives and they can't carry that
yeah
what a great man if a group of if a
generation of parents should just stop
and be like wait a minute you're 10. we
don't let you drive or drink beer so you
can't hurt my feelings like go you know
i need you to do finish your dishes or
whatever the thing yeah the world would
change on a dime